continued to play that's in balance
[Applause]
on handle and
once again after that little for 3:06
remaining in the first week week the
legs spin around drops over and have the
sweetest jumper in the league
[Music]
the Pistons wall timeout
it's simple basketball for the Cavs it's
high screen
- and putting on a Twitter gets to his
spot this vision of shouldn't
[Music]
Steph Curry averaging 24 and a half
points per game it falls down and looks
in the three anyway so make it 9:00 to
2:00 early
when nets will wind up doing a trade or
Smith or for somebody else
if you make a move with him right now to
try and get they probably could use like
that athletic
to take the
[Applause]
there is nothing that you would rather
doing a four star game but the cross
someone over make them fall and hit the
junction wanna move like Kyrie Irving
Wow the ball handling in this league
look at her Winnie Foster oh you're not
walking that close enough sorry young
boy I'm gonna have to knock this down
and get the oohs and ahhs of Houston
wonderful beautiful move by her
[Applause]
[Music]
purring my cheeks fall out of his boots
and it's a thought
you want to see a dribble move watch
this one double behind you back knock it
down and the bench is loving it coming
at Chris Paul takes it out under the
basket and suddenly goes two times
behind his back do we fall on the ground
and then finishes it off 1 2 Paul goes
down curry knocks down the jump shot
this guy is something special the beauty
box started when your energy and
attention to detail and how you finish
the gap
bring
off the spin
able to
factorable and cut to his left spanked
it up and lead us back this is just
nasty what can you say about a double
crossover look at the English on the
left hand I can understand that's the
right man but that is his offhand way to
finish strong
Kyrie are you it's kind of late oh
please pretty good fair
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Tiffin theory is so good at creating
space now with the way he handles upon
they're gonna replay that about the
basketball they give you the tube that
they're going to check on that
57 38:19 record
[Music]
[Applause]
69-55
this ball game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
disrupt a tremendous
[Applause]
you
miss Kyrie Irving boy he is so smooth at
handling the ball there's no way you can
talk about ball handling and not talk
about power yours earthen both back
between the legs pins falling away these
games please log on to nba.com or visit
the NBA app this is game on Western
Conference semifinals
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Rudy was outside of his comfort level
rated cookie has Steph Curry
keep spit take
right here don't bear they're asking him
to get out and Steph Curry with all kind
of spice goes by him full reverse which
way did it go we're gonna count the
pleases on this play
here we go
[Applause]
special curry slits the deepest behind
the back
[Applause]
just lead in the game
[Applause]
no I'm getting serious I love looking at
Steve Kerr's reaction after that move
I mean you shot as a coach as a fan as a
teammate as a play it going against it
beautiful moves down to three Oh
Kyrie masterful inside Oh always get
great it's a great defense which it was
by malcolm brogdon's
how did Kyrie get out of that
double-team Kyrie Irving comes behind
his back nice through two men including
deaf at two big steps puts it hard off
the window and in this is back tacular
bucket even by Kyrie Irving Standage
curry splits the defense behind
[Applause]
just lay another day
that could be the greatest move I've
ever seen no I'm getting serious I love
looking at Steve Kerr's reaction after
that move I mean you shot as a coach as
a fan as a teammate as a player going
against it beautiful goals Rubio
defending Mary
that's gotta be a bad feeling when you
lose your commander you're sacked
[Applause]
[Music]